you're doing some home improvements I
understand on your home yes I am oh yeah
and you put in those fancy toilets is
that right yes
you got to come over sometime I know you
won't do the guys I don't need to go I
don't need this guy come over to see
your Doyle Odyssey it's not just a
toilet it's a bidet have you heard of a
day you know Spanish this the day I'm
telling you it changes your life it's a
heated toilet seat mm-hmm and it sprays
wall wow I didn't know it sprayed the
water - I was just got it for the heated
toilet see then the water started
spraying right and there's different
speeds it's pressure difference
different pressure yeah soft medium hard
Wow enema and then have you tried this
and then the next one fire hydrant yeah
so you like this you like there's the
fracking the Fischetti level yes you're
cracking yourself up punch it I don't
need the Waterpik anymore
I don't need the Waterpik I simply use
horrible that's horrible
why you were using your water pit down
there how do you have fun you don't good
take a break we'll be right back more
with Kevin Nealon in a second you can't
use
[Applause]
you